streaming and cloud gaming are the New
Frontiers in gaming but in most cases
not the most affordable that's where the
absolute comes in once it is released
for the market it will go for around us
2049.99 that's 100 of the Logitech
clouds 349.99 but it's cheaper better in
the current state it's in no because it
is a pre-production model but it holds
so much potential at becoming the future
console that makes gaming even more
accessible without burning your wallet a
disclaimer again this is a
pre-production unit it does have its
issues that were highlighted by absolute
so I'll be talking about how it feels to
play this one so far also Xbox cloud
game is not available in our region just
yet so we'll be playing with GeForce now
PSP and steam link out of the box you
get a case that's made for the absolute
the absolute in all its Glory any USBC
cable specs wise we are in working with
4 gigs of RAM 64 gigs of internal
storage and it's running an
mt8365 chip it's also using a quad core
chip it's a four times arm cord text e53
that's clocked at 2 gigahertz it has a
USB C port for charging and file
transfers a Micro SD card slot so you
can load up whatever you want inside and
a 3.5 millimeter audio jack the absolute
is light at 450 grams it trims a lot of
fat off the steam deck that's at 669
grams it's nice and slim and the App
Store will be adding grips to the back
in the retail model it has a 7 inch ltps
screen that's in 1920x1080 and 60hz for
its refresh rate and I'll say the colors
on the screen are great at its price
point to support the shooting stars of
cloud gaming and streaming it comes
equipped with a 2T 2R mu MMO Wi-Fi chip
let's do a speed test to show you how
fast this can grow
all right here is our speed test let's
go given that Singapore and Wi-Fi also
and you know our internet speeds you up
pretty damn fast and we are at 153.09
megabytes per second now before we get
into it this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for the
sponsored message meet the Cyber 15
gaming laptop from MSI check out this
translucent material design that only
looks good but feels good thanks to its
Ultra lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7 HD series processor
and Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahimic clean speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com now the absolute
console because it's lightweight you'll
be able to hold it quite effortlessly
however when it comes to the ergonomics
it is too angular for me as it is now
the sides are much sharper than the
switch it doesn't dig in your hands of
course not but I noticed that there is a
annoying feeling after playing it for an
extended period of time also I wish they
made this group a bit much larger to be
fan the Nintendo switch Bare Bones has
no depression in the back that would act
as grips in the case absolute does not
address this issue in the retail version
I hope they are at least a third party
would craft out silicone grips like the
ones I have for my switch the material
and paint on this isn't finalized from
what I can tell but as of now it is
quite the smudge magnet so bear that in
mind the layer of the buttons and
joysticks are very similar to that of
the Nintendo switch and in turn the
Logitech G Cloud I like how the front
triggers are much longer than the
switches and it lets my fingers rest
comfortably on them and this allows me
to transition between triggers
seamlessly the joysticks are comfy the
Glide with just like the switch and
their buttons and d-pad are slightly
larger giving you a better hole of the
buttons now on to the display the colors
are Pleasant to look at not too deep and
the same goes with the blacks not only
did they get the display completely
right but they also got the speakers
right and if you're new to the channel I
redoed my audio stuff and these speakers
have done pretty well for him into the
console
[Music]
[Applause]
so right
tomorrow
the primary function of the absolute is
the stream games and the good thing
about streaming games onto a device like
this is having a good connection your PC
or PS5 has to be turned on in order for
these things to work and hopefully you
have a land cable directly connected to
them to ensure you have an amazing
stream quality we're in Singapore you
have the best internet in the world or
at least pretty close to the top so I
have no issues with streaming the games
and playing them the Wi-Fi on this is
amazing and so far I've had solid
connections there will be latency of
course but it's manageable ish butter
and sugar inputs have been consistent so
far when they do get registered we'll
talk about it later on but I will say
their triggers are very consistent and
accurate so shooting and engaging the
accelerator in racing games feels
precise and natural we have GeForce now
which lets me stream steam games in my
library that are available and
compatible again your connection
determines how smooth your game
experience is but in terms of playing on
the absolute I did enjoy playing around
with the console for the most part in a
perfect world this would have a SIM card
slot that would support 5G signals for a
truly portable game experience and also
a chance to have a leg up on Long GG
cloud and the steam deck of course the
hard fix is to carry around a portable
route to put who wants that I don't make
these devices so I would not know the
technicalities behind adding in SIM card
support but it will be a step forward
for absolute and cloud gaming consoles
in general what I didn't like the
buttons and calibration of the joysticks
on these are quite the thing to navigate
I found myself having to do a double
take on the xyab buttons or pressing
harder for an action to adjust the every
now and then especially for action games
like Coastal soshima during combat or
cyberpunk when I'm trying to just
interact with the world around me you'll
notice this when you hit the buttons
navigating the UI so a fix would be
great speaking about this the buttons do
light up you get to change the color in
the settings the d-pad however does not
and it does not let me move or perform
diagonal input smoothly I would imagine
this would be a big downside for
emulator Gamers out there when you want
to execute set the moves in game the
calibration on the joysticks as an FPS
player does not work for me especially
since they use magnetic Hall sensors
which means they practically have no
dead soon what's that zone the dead zone
is a small area around the game
controller's thumbstick that doesn't
respond to stick movement so having
literally no dead zone would mean that
every Notch would register meaning it
would be quite sensitive which would be
great for some game genres but not all
of them quite the contrast between this
and the buttons if you ask me testing
out the joysticks you'll notice that it
has a circle style input Shifting the
sticks in a diagonal it won't give you
100 of your signal slash input and that
means you won't be moving in the right
way these sticks favor cardinal points
or basically the lines so when I
shiftway diagonal it will fold the line
and then move over to your desired angle
Which is less than desirable again again
and again this is a pre-production model
and things will definitely change down
the line so what we're playing with now
maybe a whole different beast in time to
come cloud-based gaming has seen some
growth over the past decade remember on
live a cloud gaming service that started
in 2010 has seen some support from AAA
game developers like Ubisoft 2K Games
and THQ as well as gaikai which laid the
foundation of PlayStation Now however
throughout the years we've never really
seen a proper development of these
platforms that pretty much falls short
and end up being failed projects overall
my thoughts on the absolute console in
its pre-production state it can do so
much better in many areas from the
ergonomics the console to the
calibration of its joysticks and buttons
it does well in certain areas like the
Precision of its triggers it has a great
display and speakers but putting up with
its downsides makes wanting to get this
at its proposed retail price point at
U.S 2050 dollars
I'd rather get something else you can
game with it yes I do believe that
absolute is onto something here because
honestly it has the potential to be a
decent streaming and cloud gaming
console but that depends if they're able
to change things up with all the
feedback they're getting the question
remains would you get it in its current
state though no but if absolute changed
things up and meet improvements would
you get it then let me know in the
comments below and make sure to follow
us on all of our socials here to keep up
with the latest news we put out and if
you like what you're seeing hit the like
And subscribe buttons it goes a long way
in helping out the channel also if you
want to see more stuff check this out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]